i'm doing
the essentials for gq of course
what's up gq i'm camilo and these are my
10 essentials
[Music]
so i'm gonna start with this one this is
my journal this is the first thing i do
every morning in my life
like i really need to write about what
i'm feeling
how do i feel inside of my heart you
know what i'm
what i'm trying to fix in me my projects
my dreams
when i go three or four or five years
back
in my old journals and i read what i was
feeling
when i was about to release let's say my
first song and to remember that i'm
feeling the same exact thing now and how
can i like
like i don't want to repeat myself i
want to know myself so i can improve
myself
like i finish one of this every let's
say
like two months can i have them all like
in my labor i have like
hundreds like maybe a hundred i think so
so this is my journal journal like what
i'm feeling every day
but i have like a prayer journal what
i'm having like in my heart and i'm like
revisiting every day
i have a songwriting journal which is
another different one
i have um a vision journal where i like
write what i'm dreaming about and
we visited every day so i can like
that's a huge thunder second essential
for sure my guitar this is not actually
a guitar this is a guitar lele
i'm always traveling with a different
instrument not only because
it's travel size but because i wanna
get uncomfortable with my songwriting
like when i'm writing
always and just with the guitar maybe
i'm gonna start
repeating stuff and going for the same
chords that i love
but traveling with a different
instrument it's like a challenge for me
so i can start like following like a
sound
that i like right and then i start like
improvising
stuff beyond words beyond melodies
[Music]
i'm not saying anything but it sounds
great and i like it i mean i
i like it boom this is essential
if you have a mustache this is essential
for you i've been trying
every mustache walks in the world
but the only one that works the beast
walks i love it i cannot live without it
i have to take it with my nail and then
i have to warm it up
right like i have to do this a hundred
times and when it's like really
warm you can put it there and then
when it gets cold again your mustache is
where it should be right so i've been in
the position where i
lose my mustache rocks i don't know what
to do so since that moment
everybody that is around me has one my
wife has a much love
a mustache wax my manager has one in the
car in the guitar in the nylon guitar
and the ukulele my photographer
everybody has one because if i lose this
and i don't have it
i cannot fix it my mustache
inspiration would be pancho vida
his mustache was on point the leaf
mustache was a little
thinner and way longer but pancho villa
was like
kind of this mustache he's my mustache
inspiration
this is essential for me
kindle the thing with the kindle is that
at the beginning i was holding myself
from having it because i'm a huge fan of
real books
and i read a lot but the thing is when
you travel all the time with
seven books it's like exhausting
a thunder we're in the middle of that
dominican republic a lot of thunders
like of course there's books that i
don't want to have here because i want
to have them like
and smell the lasso like the pages right
i love that but this is awesome
so another essential
peace honey my parents are beekeepers
that's their their main thing in their
lives you know beekeeping and my life
was
all around peace that's why i have a bee
here
and so honey it's like part of my life
like every day i'm using it for
something different from a scrub like if
i'm feeling bad with my throat and
whatever honey you know like that's part
of
who i am this is my sister brand
so we all like in my family love honey
it's part of our lives
my yoga mat
[Music]
to be honest this is not my yoga mat
like i'm gonna
do yoga every day but i just like look
for one
and most of the times in the hotels they
don't have yoga mats or
some don't have and i do it with a towel
i've been practicing ashtanga yoga for
at least
i think like eight years ago when i
started meditating when i started
breathing with conscience it's about
a philosophy of life of unity me as an
artist i'm part of a very
stimulating industry with a lot of ups
and downs you know
you should have a practice and a
discipline that brings you
down to earth and to connect with who
you really
am that is not the charts the songs the
concerts the sold-outs
but that that is inside of you and yoga
brings me
back to that you know so a very
important part
of my life too and a very essential part
[Music]
it's my jewelry like my earrings
my necklaces like i don't use them
just for how they look every one of them
holds like a part of my journey in my
story you know
like i was telling you guys this and the
bee is part of like the
like el emblema like the picture of my
family
beekeeping honey bees you know let's say
this
says why and i have it it's it's my
brother-in-law's and it's talk about my
why and every time i see it i remember
why i'm doing what i'm doing you know
my earring every little thing that it's
like hanging in my earring
holds a little story you know like of a
very important
dinner that i have with my wife that i
really remember the first
gift that my brothers-in-law gave me
when we started writing together
that was the start point of my career
the e of my wife eva luna
and she has a c and i have an e so we
feel like we're together with that
i don't know it doesn't mean that we are
more together because of that but it's
like a reminder you know it's beautiful
my wedding ring i mean it's just a ring
or not it's like a reminder of a
beautiful and spiritual mystical bond
that you have
with the most important person of your
life every little
detail that i wear in my body
means something and carries some a
message
and a a part of who i am not only
aesthetic wise
but storytelling wives right so another
one
coconut oil i love coconut oil
and i use it for everything like i mean
it's part of my daily life
in different aspects in the shower i use
it when
you have to do like uh like a scrub
you use it in the shakes like if i'm in
a very dry place
i use this as a moisturizer when you do
coffee and coconut oil and you shake it
like in a blender like it's kind of like
a latte
me and my wife we use it for everything
so peppermint essential oil
this is very important and it's always
in my
bag in my backpack in my mochila with me
all the time
because we use it every day for
everything if you have
headache mean
if you're dc this is the best like in
the
lengua boom little drop and that's it if
you have like a cold
or like difficulty with breathing we use
it all the time
we use it for the inhalers the the
vaporizer
the little things that like like the spa
things
from massages in the candles in the tea
for everything this is like our medicine
every day
this is essential for me too
my pintura is my nail paint
in my nails i have a little dot in every
one of them
like i used it once to remind myself
of like i love the the poetry in the
image of god
creating us from the dust you know from
the floor from nothing
like from nothing special at all and
it's exactly
the the spirit the breathing the rua
they say in the hebrew culture the rua
that made us
unique and special but it's a beautiful
reminder that yes we are divine but
yes we are nothing dust
and that's a reminder of that and i used
it once and when i tried to
take it out like i felt like naked like
when you're lacking something like oh my
god i need this and i did
it again and since that moment like
three years ago
i haven't stopped and my hands are all
the time
in camera in the scene in the guitar
in the spot you know and i want every
little detail and corner of
my person to share a message you know
where you were what you share what do
you
your hair your your face your eyes your
mannose
they're sharing a message all the time
i'm a very passionate person about
the impression that you make on people
so
to be honest i haven't thought about
doing anything else because this
is part of who i am
thank you guys so much for checking out
my essentials i'm camilo
thank you for having me here and see you
next time ciao